el estrés y la depresión aumenta en esta
temporada de fin de año y ahora este
2020 se le ha sumado la pandemia cómo
podemos reducir al mínimo el estrés la
tristeza o la ansiedad
ellos es objetivamente estamos expuestos
como nunca
- la memoria de cualquiera de las
asociaciones que viven actualmente
a una situación que no sé naturalmente
no tiene que preocuparnos tienes que
expresar que y que ha generado pérdidas
tanto la depresión está también
creciendo en muchas partes del mundo
como respuesta de la pandemia eso no
quiere decir que los seres humanos no
tengamos capacidad para enfrentar estas
adversidades y a pesar de que este es un
pedido como usted bien lo señala donde
este tipo de problema se tiende a elevar
hay sin embargo este también es donde el
paso que podemos aprovechar las personas
para sacar para hacer uso de aquellos
recursos que están a nuestra disposición
y que permiten contrarrestar eso déjeme
contarle en particular algunas de las
personas que nos encontramos los que
podemos encontrarnos con pocos cuando
está en estos días pero también podemos
conectarnos
la simple investigación psicológica
mostrado de la gratitud la expresión de
la gratitud el reconocimiento de lo que
otros nos han dado nosotros que a otros
es una especie tiene un efecto positivo
no solamente era aquellos que nos siguen
la expresión del efectivo sino que muy
particularmente les expresan gratitud es
decir estamos en la posición la posición
totalmente de protegernos de una
adversidad a central lo que por los
batidos empleo muy muy profundamente y
en estos días de navidad que es
reconocer que a pesar de todo lo que
estamos ante hay razones para ser el
presente con muchas personas psicólogo
psicólogo más si hay lo interrumpo para
que nos siga dando más recomendaciones
también ahí detectó algún sonido no sé
si con su mano le está golpeando a la
computadora al año pasado era distinto
no había una crisis sanitaria de por
medio es entendible entonces que estamos
sintiendo esta frustración que
recomienda para finalizar al respecto
bueno yo diría que psicológicamente hay
probablemente esto en estos días del
cumplido que hay dos conceptos y los
cinco mil trabajos la empatía y negativo
la empatía nos conecta con los demás
nos hace sentir los comprendidos y
podemos comprender a otros especialmente
en estos días en que es tan difícil
sobrellevar este problema eso es muy
necesario y como decía se emplea
gratitud es otro recurso sobre los ticos
fundamental que favorecen nuestro
bienestar que promueven seres positivos
por tanto de contrarrestar el riesgo de
depresión y además genera aún optimismo
y apoyo social que es algo que tanto
necesitamos búsqueda podría intentar
comenzando a operar